I've been covering the ways in which
Donald Trump has been sort of placating
the alt-right and neo-nazis and white
supremacists and it might all be merely
appeasement with no policy connected to
it that would be bad enough but given
Trump's policy ideas about immigration
and Hispanic individuals and Mexico and
all of that stuff it's pretty clear that
there is actually at least some policy
but behind the horrible horrible
comments that have been made by Donald
Trump and so look to give you one
example America first right we talked
about America first maybe a seemingly
innocuous patriotic slogan it actually
has its roots in a hugely xenophobic and
white supremacist movement from the
early 20th century which we've outlined
before lots of other examples the new
one that I want to talk about today is
Trump referring to immigrants
reproducing having children as quote
breeding this is a term that the white
supremacists absolutely love and you
might hear that and say you know usually
we call it human reproduction or we call
it having kids breeding it's almost like
a term we would use when we talk about
animal reproduction and that is exactly
why white supremacists love the use of
the term breeding when talking about
brown-skinned
immigrants having children because it
indirectly refers to them like animals
Donald Trump tweeted late last week
there is a revolution going on in
California so many sanctuary areas want
out of this ridiculous crime-infested
and breeding concept Jerry Brown is
trying to back out of the National Guard
at the border but the people of the
state are not happy want security and
safety now referring to immigrant
reproduction especially Hispanic
immigrants in California as breeding is
a way to dehumanize the idea that they
infest and they breed and they bring
with them horrible things and it's not a
random term that Trump just used and it
has the
of side-effect of dehumanizing
immigrants it's something that goes back
a long time we can go all the way back
to 1919 Adolf Hitler's first
anti-semitic writings talked about
inbreeding Jews and he used the term
many more times in the decades that
followed but it's very easy to say oh
come on David going back to the early
20th century and Hitler it's almost
apocryphal even if true at least in
reference to Trump fine you don't need
to go to Hitler go to Trump appointee
Karl Higby who resigned after we learned
that he referred to black women as
thinking quote breeding is a form of
government employment look at the wildly
racist Republican Congressman Steve King
who said about immigrants screening
quote you get the pick of the litter and
you got yourself a pretty good bird dog
again referring to immigrants as animals
you look at Dan Stein from the
anti-immigration Federation for American
immigration reform who said immigrants
are doing competitive breeding to reduce
the white majority and even look at
former guests on this program and widely
known white nationalist Richard Spencer
talking about quote interracial breeding
the debate has mostly become whether
Trump is deliberately saying this stuff
to placate white supremacists and I
would argue it doesn't matter right
because the real question is are the
white supremacists reacting to the
language and the answer is that yes they
are they selectively ignore Trump's
Jewish daughter from Jewish son-in-law
Trump's Jewish grandchildren and they
see these references and they are
emboldened they see this and they say
that's a signal from Trump it's a signal
from Trump that he's one of us and if
you're against white supremacy which
many Trump supporters claim to be you
have to call this stuff out and you have
to denounce it whether or not it's
deliberate because it's not like most
presidents are constantly accidentally
appeasing white supremacists and we just
have to kind of deal with it a standard
operating procedure Trump is an outlier
in this regret and it has to be called
out in this regard rather unless you
agree with
it which of course many trumpets do they
should all say I agree with the guy on
taxes I agree with the guy on trade but
America first and talking about
immigrants breeding it's got to be
called out and unfortunately too many
trumpets are completely indifferent to
the fact that he's using this language
yeah I do think it's an open question as
to whether this was a dog whistle and
Trump knew what he was doing or if it's
just something in his subconscious and I
don't know if we'll ever get to the
bottom of that is he actually a racist
or does he just say racist things does
he have a few racist views it's pretty
open-ended I don't know it is and
increasingly I think it doesn't matter I
mean when Trump was a candidate it was a
it was an interesting question was he
doing all of the things that he was
doing and saying Hispanics you know
rapists and whatever although some I'm
guessing I'm sure good people the making
fun of the disabled reporter all of that
stuff before it was sort of an academic
or theoretical question is someone
writing this stuff forum is someone
telling him to do these things is it a
reflection of a sincerely held beliefs
what is it
it's less relevant now because now the
impact is that it has catalyzed some of
the most disgusting and depraved and
vile to use some of the David Pakman
bingo buzzword it has catalyzed some of
these horrible horrible groups they see
Trump as their guy we see from the
organizations that track hate groups
including the anti-defamation league in
the Southern Poverty Law Center that
there is a revitalization of these
groups so what we now need to focus on
is not actually what is deep in Trump's
brain and you know what there are people
on the right who should appreciate that
because there's people on the right who
always like to say you can't really know
what's in someone's heart or what's in
someone's mind no matter how racist what
they say might seem to be you don't
really know what their beliefs are fine
I'm admitting to the idea that we can
move on from that we have to focus on
the impact and the impact is a disaster
and Trump says these the least racist
person that you know yeah so I guess we
got to take him at his word
yeah which is a really hard to believe
word to take him at send me your
thoughts about this send me your
thoughts about the use of this term we
are on facebook at facebook.com slash
david pakman show interesting 2018
midterm race update
coming up next today's episode of the
David Pakman show is made possible in
part by Cody which is an innovative new
cryptocurrency and online payment
platform that is setting out to
revolutionize how we send and receive
online payments the same way that the
transportation industry has been
innovated by ride-sharing apps the same
way that music and video distribution
have been revolutionized by real-time
streaming cody says that the payment
industry is ripe for transformation
right now cody stands for currency of
the internet and they're setting out to
make their cryptocurrency which was
designed specifically to be used for
payments that will be the first crypto
if they succeed used on a widespread
mainstream basis for online payments
this will be payment system that can be
used by anyone whether you're a consumer
or a business and regardless of the
industry that you're in most Kryptos
fail to meet the everyday needs of
average consumers or businesses and many
crypto currencies just weren't built
with convenient and trustworthy payment
as their sort of primary function and
this is the specific niche that Cody is
trying to fill with the technology that
they've created you're watching this on
youtube you can find out more about Cody
and their ICO in the links below the
video this is not financial advice and
you should do all of your own research
before making any investment decisions